Professor Hodgkin...
...should be much better known
than she is.
Scientists admire the great
determination and skill
which has always been
the mark of your work.
She was a highly intelligent,
highly focused scientist.
She would keep going,
whatever the difficulties.
You just solve the next small problem
and eventually the whole problem
will crack.
Involving what can only be described
as gifted intuition.
She was a peace lover.
She believed in solving problems
by dialogue and not by confrontation.
In recognition of your
services to science...
She's the only British woman
scientist ever to have won
a Nobel prize...
...For chemistry.
What was it about Dorothy
that made is possible
for her to achieve
the things she did,
at a time when so few women
had those opportunities?
Dorothy was born in Cairo,
her father was very interested
in archaeology
as was her mother.
If there was a dig, archaeological
dig, she would try and join in.
She also had this amazing ability
for recognising patterns
and symmetry,
and her notebooks show that, from
when she was really quite young.
When World War One broke out,
Dorothy and her then two sisters
were brought back to England.
She was essentially left
as the head of the family.
She had to worry about whether there
was enough money in the bank account.
Her interest in chemistry
started when she was only
about the age of 10,
when she went to a little
tiny primary school
where they grew crystals
and she said herself,
"I was captured for life
by chemistry and by crystals."
When Dorothy was in her teens,
one of the discoverers
of x-ray crystallography
talked about this technique
that allows you to see where the
atoms are in the molecule
and how they're arranged in space,
and so she read about
being able to see atoms
and said to herself there and then,
"That's what I want to do."
In lectures she was
extremely well-known
for seemingly having gone to sleep,
and yet at the end, Dorothy would ask
the most piercing question.
She clearly wasn't asleep.
What personal qualities have
helped you in the work?
In some ways, I suppose, a certain
kind of foolhardiness
for going on, doing things
that other people don't expect
is quite possible to do.
I think a lot of girls grow up
with a sense
that they don't have the permission
to do things they might want to do.
One of the characteristics that
Dorothy's upbringing gave her
was a tremendous sense of agency.
When she got married,
she was asked to stand down
from her fellowship at college.
Eventually this was changed,
and she also managed to be awarded
maternity leave.
She was the first woman to have
that at the University of Oxford.
It paved the way for other women
who wanted to have a fulfilled
scientific life
and also to have a family.
After Dorothy's first child was born,
she suffered an attack of acute
rheumatoid arthritis
and left her with distorted
hands and feet.
As she got older,
the arthritis did recur
but she didn't let it hold her back.
Dorothy was very much engaged
in international issues
and so she was vehemently opposed
to the war in Vietnam
and indeed visited north Vietnam.
She did travel extensively and
she made a point of visiting,
first of all, the Soviet Union,
and subsequently China.
It was the height of the Cold War,
but scientific relations continued
and she was always very keen
to make contact.
Internationalism was a very big part
of her make-up.
Dorothy remains the only
woman scientist
in this country to win a Nobel prize.
The determination of the
structure of vitamin B12
has been considered
the crowning triumph
of x-ray crystallographic analysis.
The Daily Mail ran the headline
'Housewife wins Nobel prize'.
The reaction of newspapers in the 60s
whenever women achieved anything
was absolutely appalling.
Dorothy's influence
on modern medicine
is almost incalculable.
All the problems that Dorothy
chose to work on
were problems that would contribute
to a better understanding
of the body in health and disease.
Penicillin. The knowledge of its
structure was enormously important
in the Second World War.
Its structure was not understood
until she solved it.
It enabled doctors to use materials
that had been synthesised
in a laboratory and apply those
to the sick patients.
The way in which those drugs
are made now
rely a lot on the structure that
Dorothy determined.
She gave the impression
to those who didn't know her perhaps
of being a frail old lady,
which of course she wasn't.
There was nothing frail
about Dorothy's mind, attitude,
kindness and so on.
Dorothy should be remembered
for blazing a trail, really,
for showing that women
can be scientists
and not only be scientists, but be
extremely successful scientists.
She gave to the world
the knowledge
but also the way to do it,
the determination not to give up.
If you know and think you can do it,
keep working at it.
And if that's not the definition
of exceptional,
I'm not sure what is.
Thank you, Doctor Hodgkin.